Bruce Willis's big break in Show
Business came in 1985 when Moonlighting
became a pop culture phenomenon he
eventually parlayed his TV stardom into
a career as a leading man in feature
films with his big screen leading debut
in 1987's blind dates then in 1988
Willis appeared in what would become his
signature role John mlan the hard luuck
protagonist of Die Hard and its
subsequent four sequels welcome to the
party pal audiences clearly took a
liking to his di hard Persona as well as
the movie because it opened the door for
a new chapter in his career as both an
action star and a major Marquee name
nevertheless Willis leaves behind a
truly impressive body of work for
audiences to enjoy